dort wird gesponsert vom toyota auris
hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und wer
trotzdem elektrischem appell macht
gebeten
[Musik]
die auch das macht ja ganz im harz ja
gut im griff
bisher sehe ich auch nicht unbedingt an
[Musik]
global office web apps ich glaube das
sehen wo es kein unterschied zwischen
ihrer liebe zur schönen momente beträgt
unruhig tanzen ängste wie eigentlich
ausgeben und als als teenager auf der
bühne gestanden
und ja größter sie will singen und hatte
wieder massiv schicksals fix ist einfach
wirst du sie ganz klar
[Musik]
so haben peter zu und mark angefangen
das traum trio der 70er jahre
[Musik]
si
junge stimmen proben die hits von peter
sue und marc für das musical
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bleibt für viele betriebe dir doch bitte
mal da
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
so klingt peter rivas musik neu
aufbereitet für das risiko hast du
einfach mitmachen durch glauben sind
sport und lifestyle hinterher 40 jahre
nach ihren größten erfolgen steht das
trio wieder im rampenlicht mit allem was
das showbiz verlangt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
naja
ja klar
[Musik]
ja
pauli
[Musik]
das musical erzählt eine dramatische
liebesgeschichte natürlich mit happy end
das war schon besser es ist dem bergwald
natürlich wieder es einfach schön dass
die leute von ihr vor mit hilfe von 40
jahren gehört noch mehr als die jetzt
klar dass die normale bönnigheimer und
berufen dass er schon wieder mehr stark
zulegen
halici china telecom augusta das
verstecken
[Musik]
peterson und marc auf dem weg zum
eurovision song contest 1971 in dublin
[Musik]
wer mir auch so
diese vision und innovator wird zu ihrem
ersten hit
[Musik]
lasst uns jungen doch die illusionen
paar ist die botschaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der sound der straße tönt weniger
versöhnlich in diesen wilden jahren nach
[Musik]
es ist der sound von jimi hendrix der
sound der region
[Musik]
als sich die steuer der jugend gegen die
ungerechtigkeit der welt und gegen das
establishment
in dublin wird der trave sound aus der
schweiz belohnt platz zwölf und ein
plattenvertrag für peterson und mag
[Musik]
ich war frisiert
ein rebell musik machen und nicht auf
den trick schlagen wo sie mit dem bier
luft stars und die nummer der apple-weg
genauer gesagt hat war kid rocks und
easy sex oder wiesen das interessiert
und die eben mehr für evolution als für
evolution und die richter und den sie
mit ganz am anfang erklärt und sie quasi
als folk trio finden das schon cooler
betrag reduzieren und klar aber ich
meine ist die grafik sie sind ja ihr
braucht sollte ich weiß nicht was er hat
so stolz sie wenn irgendwo weiter stehen
mit den bereichen genetik typisch harz
und im programm diskutieren kein theater
liberi nexium man sie aus max ist der
und trotzki stieg sie betreten sexy wie
militärdienst und direkt am kassa und
sich folgende mache mit pflicht
das land bietet tv solvenz machen wir
das wenn es mit berufung bin heute stolz
darauf dass sicherheit macht weil die
dir gemacht
es steht eben einfach sie wenigstens
eine abart chaos biologiestudenten xii
[Musik]
angefangen haben peter sue und marc als
protestsänger doch bald ändert sich ihr
stil
[Musik]
die show wird immer wichtiger
illustriert die finanzen im trio über
die musikalische ausrichtung dass sie
mit verschiedenen wenig und zwar zu sie
glauben ja doch auch die saubere
gundelfinger im volkslied ist für mich
musik wichtig statt
der text kommt interessiert ob es
protest oder das liebesleben besonders
wenn mit melody konnte sie einfach rein
ich spüre dass uns mitzufahren
ich werde mit einer korrektur melodie
league steht und kein plötzlicher jetzt
zwei kennen das erste mal zusammen zu
haben und durchaus zu stehen mit der
sache machen dass viele wahnsinnig und
wer ist überhaupt nicht im zentrum
stange sondern das bedürfnis mit rang
zehn mit etwas gesucht wird die drei
stehen
wie schon das tor wie schon musik ist
das taxi und außer andere schlechtere
im free-tv mark sind nur noch selten
heute heißt der coco und ist wird an der
berner frühlingsmesse bea
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die berner fasnacht hat er vor 19 jahren
gegründet seine neue bühne
mit dem habe ich mir nicht möglich war
sagte haspa nicht vorstellbar
ich habe mich ob sie lügt empfahl das
fasnachts space league wieder für
vereinen fasnacht übrigens machen da
sitzt das soll die von ferien und so
sie machen ganze züge begegnungen im
volk hier steuer ist kaum ein jahr lang
ist das stück auf jw menschen herum ska
und reggae hit machen ist das trio
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der 3
[Musik]
so
ab 3
so ging es nicht immer so gut
[Musik]
zuerst stürzte er ab mit alkohol
später kam eine existenzielle
lebenskrise
seine rettung war tricks die dritte
ehefrau von coco sie wirkt im
hintergrund und ist der ruhige polen in
seinem leben
ohne seine tricks wäre ja heute nicht
mehr hier
doch davon später
[Musik]
so heißt jetzt susan shell
sie hat sich zurückgezogen in appenzell
[Musik]
fern vom rampenlicht hat sie eine neue
existenz aufgebaut
sie experimentiert mit alten
volksliedern und filmt sich dabei und
überprüft wie sie wirkt
[Musik]
alle zwei wochen gibt sie ins nahe
altersheim
[Musik]
ja
cawley
[Musik]
mehr
wenn ihr auch die treffer für die u 23
und und hat kontakt herstellen und die
wir normal alt und sind nie wunder wir
dass sie antreten
du bist schön die frau war so wild wie
gast um mit dem eigenen alter das ich
zum glück ein langsamer prozess zieht
sich ja immer noch attraktiv
[Musik]
er ist ziemlich schnell die liebe ist
nicht von dauer
zu unterschiedlich sind die beiden
[Musik]
ich glaube zu der zeit zu der der
anfangszeit mit den songs kraft und
engagement stück
[Musik]
doch bald wird aus der engagierten
folksängerin ein paradies foren für das
massenpublikum
der typische peter reber sound macht das
trio zur erfolgreichsten bands der 70er
jahre
[Musik]
mit ios and hatte schaffen sie den
internationalen durchbruch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch das trio löst sich auf dem
höhepunkt auf
[Musik]
ihr mann
warum sie sich trennen bleibt ihr
geheimnis
die drei wollen nicht über die wahren
gründe sprechen
[Musik]
wie viel zeit wir haben also und der
musiker stark sich zu erinnern
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
mitglieder leute
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zu startet eine eigene karriere alle hin
jetzt ist ganz aus ganz anders im leben
oder wie sozial ist das große umstellung
ist das gut also besser so so wissen zu
arbeiten ist mehr freiheit oder ist es
angst du alles was du sagst weil das ja
das ist besser das ist belastende das
ist beängstigend das ist befreiend sein
alles was neu ist bewiesen dass sie so
wenig und unabhängig vom trio das
honeywell und johanna hörter vertrag
über 100 metronome und freddy burger
management und die herrlich meter große
status mir und es ist einfach schwierig
wurde hey sie schmeckt und hayley harnik
mit zum beispiel ich frage mich was
harry für das image und die dann
zusammenhang ist nach 1978 mit meiner
fotografie krebs der station gemacht und
jetzt ganz toll da kommt mir doch etwas
machen und dann tot xxl soziales
professionelles studio und weiß in weiß
mit weißem hintergrund
ja und ich bin nicht ganz glücklich
ihre zweite platte wird zum flop die
plattenfirma kündigt den vertrag auch
die dritte platte manchmal bleibt ohne
resonanz ende der solokarriere
[Musik]
das bin was haben weil wir ohne mich von
meinen lieben die sängerin laufbahn
anstreben und das mit ganz ganz schlecht
[Musik]
um ihn bewegt
ja und jetzt ist das sexy und habe mir
nicht seine trainerkarriere anna gekannt
oha gesperrt immer setzt nach china
[Musik]
peters tochter nina ist primarlehrerin
und komponiert kinderlieder
[Musik]
horn machte in dem islamischen welt
sie arbeiten am lied ich bin der adler
you
[Musik]
hinten
peter reitz seine tochter schon ganz
früh ans rampenlicht gewöhnt
[Musik]
es stehen
die verbreitete extrem spiel für hormone
oder ist das bewusstsein altenteil für
den morgen oder wechseln wird
mit diesen markt geregelt des rail seine
mitglieder und wie jeder miteinander
schritt und es gibt sachen den
armenischen wenn man ist doch nicht
wenige ist aber ich komme wieder
ich hoffe ist die zusagen und
sicherheiten schön informierten familien
und paare haley ist doch es gilt noch
heute war welches wort im tiebreak soll
es ist so
soweit es das habe ich natürlich mein
neues album von der grauenhaften
abhängig
[Musik]
peter präsentiert seine familien idylle
in videobotschaften an das schweizer
fernsehpublikum
fr
moz
kaum
sieben jahre sind peter und livia
unterwegs die filmkamera ist immer dabei
peter komponiert hundert lieder über
sehnsucht mehr und insel glückseliger
[Musik]
sorge in einem rekord liegt bei
petrograd is now die lieder aus
musikalische grüße schickt mit den
garantierte sieht man ihr vor meter pck
wenn ich das mal für alle klicks das war
über machen und der herzlich für ihre
werke dass sie trotzdem gegen die zur
musik zu erkunden
es ist zuge und turbo oder für die reden
willst dich gesehen ja gut die glut
einer exotischen aus marketing das
genauso aber das ist die schrecken zu
versetzen versorger logisch einen
vertrag erhält beim schopf packt wird
das nie gemacht habe
das wetter wahrscheinlich ganz viel mut
machen und die haste quasi er sagt wie
es für sie teurer machen
[Musik]
er biete gut die 10
geschehen
[Musik]
die rega familie vereint in der tv-show
in der sendung die grössten schweizer
hits und peter reber den zweiten rang
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es gibt und wie gut muss aber eben auch
kitsch liebe ist wichtig und das
liebeslied die frage steht ein und
bestätigt das lied ist so viel zusammen
der sich über die kic vielseitige was in
ihr leben
diese fehler kritisch wie versucht ich
weiß etwas für mich das nie kritisch für
mehr ist es nicht schrieb a ha und das
wird bei ex hochzeit gezogen die marge
für hätte sie genau das was sie ihre
frau kein wetter sei die marke reber
funktioniert als kleinunternehmen livia
ist das herz der administration und
verwaltet sein musikalisches werk bis
heute verkaufte peter 1,3 millionen
tonträger und holte 37 mal gold oder
platin für seine platten auch dank
ehefrau livia
die beiden sind seit 38 jahren ein paar
dass dieses foulspiel begangen ich br
fallen die flocken auch eigentlich alles
zusammen
operativ lag vor allem der internet shop
wo alles was zu tun ist und deine vor
allem auch viel mit welt dreifach mutter
sie mit der einfach sachen mode absage
wenn ihnen gut mit ist schön aber ich
bin nicht in form
es ist nicht ein krieg also wenn wir es
so langsam ist
jetzt ist unser messi und also
irgendetwas ist heute so wenig ein und
die wahnsinnig großes dass sie etwas
ausmacht das nikon der mache und ich
mache lieber nicht sagen sie
livia und peter sind auch sozial und
politisch engagiert zb in der förderung
von jugend musik in benefizkonzerten
oder in der aktion musik für
straßenkinder
[Musik]
peter hat sich von ganz unten
hochgearbeitet
die partie ist ganz einfach sie aber der
kita madagaskar und das fing nach wie
vor sehr wichtig dass man gewisse
chancengleichheit oder der start kriegen
sie das mit der bav dass jeder eine
chance aber nicht muss die chance packen
haus die möglichkeiten von ios beste
machen wohin sie während der wm hatte
oder tonträger verkaufte 1000 jetzt
schon ich habe wahnsinnig rammte zwei
jahren im trio die anderen zwei monate
fehlen sich eine andere produziert für
andere geschrieben
ich habe mich dasselbe verdient
[Musik]
auch coco hat viel geld verdient mit
peter sue und marc geblieben ist nichts
er lebt von der rente und arbeitet
gelegentlich als diplomierter
stadtführer für bären tourismus hier
lieber leute sehen sie den sieg locker
das war eben nach der ersten stadt
bauphase ist okay gegeben die wir haben
die nationalbank die kantonalbank und
dann die regionalbank wie das targo
quasi zurückgeschickt sogenannt bürger
durch alaba um die ja natürlich lang
lang hatte yunus k s bisher bisherigem
stand dass sie sich nicht also ja immer
da wo der teure knoten zu machen
der taucher kommt mit dem unrentablen
ein geschäft dass mark aufmacht und mit
dem alkohol
[Musik]
eigentlich sind mit eigenbau verlässt
seine frau und die zwei söhne und
verkauft seine villa zum beispiel mit
der erste flug und so ja es gibt schon
moment ganz so als single genießt er die
neue freiheit mit zahlreichen
liebschaften
es wird zwar nennt herum
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ruhiger wird coco erst als diese frau
auf dem sozius steigt tricks die dritte
ehefrau
[Musik]
dixie und das ist ja nicht umbringt es
ist interessant das ist lustig aber es
war eine tolle bedingt genau mit tipps
und dann aber gemerkt das ist ganz
andere debatte hatte eben auch wenn das
letzte mittel sein
hans dampf in allen gassen hängt ohne
sehen
[Musik]
2005 kommt die zweite lebenskrise
herzinfarkt depressionen
selbstmordgedanken ja einfach mehr
jetzige stütze technisches xxx
die welt rückt wenn sie nicht was
passiert wäre wenn die technik überzeugt
dass sie nicht nachvollziehen was
passiert war konnte es gar nicht gut war
es ist extrem und kirche ist einfach
wichtig sie für den google verliert den
job und geht von sich aus straßen putzen
einfach so in bayern in jaffa die
vollkommen recht seiner last not least
die achtlos und sogar noch chile
kartoffelsuppe die stadt und 112
befristeten auftrag oder koffer starb
ein effektiv terminierung galizier und
das mache ich glaube ja denn er bewegt
ja
susan shell auf ihrem weg nach innen
sie sucht neue ausdrucksformen mit
körperbewegung und tönen kämen
tanzend die dämmerung tanzend auf denen
die zeit
[Musik]
für sie ist das eine heilende arbeit
mit stimme und klavier sie gefühle frei
lägen und ausdrücken können
[Musik]
was sie fühlt hat sie auf einer cd
veröffentlicht
das vorspiel und zwar ist melodie
formulierte ziel und die harte texte zur
gemacht zeit zum thema im inland okay
[Musik]
das 1
in ein neues land wenn der weg noch weit
[Musik]
mit kokos fasnachts keller in der berner
altstadt
angesagt ist sohn bruno dietrich mit
seiner band friends so soll die boards
gibt dann mit frischem blut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin
k
[Musik]
annika
the fame monster
[Musik]
chicago
sport
vor
nicht besser ergeht
[Musik]
die palliativstation im kantonsspital st
gallen
natürlich gerne bis vier zähler nach
das ganze songs machen
sie ist freiwillige des hospizdienstes
vom schweizerischen roten kreuz und
steht schwerkranken menschen bei
ja und einfach
[Musik]
ja
premiere des musicals horsesense hatte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit mitnehmen
ich darf wir prämieren ich sagen es sind
mallorcas gestartet
das sind rückschläge messe vorstellen
sie berät und qualität setzen und die
musik normaler aus bonität skibbe hat
[Musik]
ja
dass der laden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das musst du dich grüner bogen auflief
menschen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ratlos
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dog mit toyota auris hybrid
er braucht keine steckdose und wer
trotzdem elektrisch